we are learning new information about
the gruesome beheading of a woman near
minneapolis this week
and why the alleged killer was free to
walk the streets in the first place
today police charging alexis sabarit
with second-degree intentional
murder for his role in the death of
america thayer
local reports suggest sabarat was
released on bond this spring
after allegedly trying to burn down his
apartment in 2020
just three years after he was convicted
of domestic assault charges
in 2017. here now vince collins radio
host and editorial director
of the daily caller a very busy man
great story at the daily caller covering
this
it's important these are the things that
americans need to know about what's
transpiring in great american cities
give us a picture about why this is even
possible right now vince
yeah when we often when we talk about
crime you know a lot of focus is of
course placed on the police
but it's not just the police and our
criminal justice system that needs to
work it's the prosecutors and it's the
courts as well
and this beheading this week is going to
place a lot of focus
on the court that released this guy
ultimately he's got a couple of
convictions
in his past one of them for domestic
abuse the the initials
match up with america thayer here the
idea being that he probably domestically
abused her in 2017
before he subsequently now murdered her
and as you mentioned he apparently tried
to set fire to his own apartment last
year
and that led to a court hearing this
spring where a court doctor recommended
that he be taken into custody and held
there because he is a threat to the
community
the judge released him and now this is
the result
would you say i mean it seems to be
clear that the rhetoric that is coming
out of washington
out of certain politicians that defund
the police movement
this rejection of justice and
repercussions
and responsibility that this is what is
driving this would you agree with that
a consequence-free world is a world in
which criminals thrive and that is what
we've created i
look to here in dc nya courtney six
years old
killed two fridays ago now on the
streets of d.c gunned down in the middle
of the night the person who killed her
already was uh in trouble in maryland
this past year for an illegal weapons
charge and grand theft auto
uh this is this is typical these are
criminals who get released back into the
public
and then go up go on to commit heinous
acts of violence
you know and people think some people
are being told or believe this is just
some natural progression of evil america
this is the result of policy as well
it's a result of rhetoric
when they can't they're oh we're not
going to defund the police the rhetoric
has made it impossible for the police to
do their job so the police resign
or they move on to some other career or
or they quit whatever they do
but this is the end result of the
democratic mindset
it's an extraordinary development and
it's affecting every city not just blue
cities at this point
and it's the product of democrats who
don't feel that they need to actually
change the laws in order to change what
the laws are you're looking at district
attorneys states attorneys commonwealth
attorneys
across the country who are being put
into place by wealthy liberal donors
like george soros has definitely done
this
he's bankrolled these types of campaigns
in order to get these guys to not
prosecute crimes it's a big deal yeah
this is this is a
an agenda it is planned it's a strategy
and it and it's
paid for vince great thank you very much
for